All right.
Well, we're about
10 seconds from liftoff. Let's l
Five, four, three, two, one.
It is full power.
And liftoff and go.
Accident
Copy.
What happened?
Together, we expand what is poss
in low-Earth orbit.
Ad Astra and Godspeed X to
me.
Plus 30 seconds into this histor
T plus 36 seconds.
36 seconds in the flight.
A great deal of Falcon nine
having the space
telemetry is like one around
power telemetry normal.
We're into the throttle bucket
as the first stages
throttle down power on the Merli
in preparation for Max Q
Falcon nine is supersonic
faster than the speed of sound
as we're getting great views
from the first stage camera.
Looking back at Kennedy
Space Center complex, 39 a
stage one throttle up next Q
Out of the
throttle bucket stage one bravo,
copy one bravo.
We're in full power
and I call on one bravo.
That's another one of those apar
as we get higher and faster.
The logic for Dragon
should a contingency occur, chan
from stage to show is underway.
Chill Announcement says
we're getting the turbo pump
on the second stage
engine cooled down in preparatio
for its light up.
Coming up in
just another minute from now,
Again great is looking back
and you can see the contrail
as we left 39 and the
the shadow of the contrail
against the cloud deck around Fl
and we're coming up
three big sequence and a view
live of the crew inside dragon
they're getting ready
we're going to get three events
main engine cut off stage one 30
and then we're going to
light the second stage engine
we've heard the throttle down
in preparation for stage separat
because
upper
stage separation confirmed
copy to alpha
and back initial
stage.
What this start up
All right.
Stage separation.
We've lit the second stage engin
The first stage is into the boos
back burn
working its way back
towards Cape Canaveral
is on the left side.
That's the first stage engines r
As we come back to the launch si
or the landing site,
second stage
engine nozzle
is visible on the right side
as we're powering the Axiom two
into low-Earth orbit
on the way
to the International Space Stati
Waiting for call out
that the booster back burn is co
stage one, this back shutdown
right on time.
First stage
completed the first of three bur
heading back to the landing site
second stage
continuing on power and on traje
acquisition signal for me to
head northeast
the Bermuda ground stations basi
trajectory nominal
Bermuda is listening in to the v
in nominal trajectory
and the crew hears
the call out of a nominal trajec
So 4 minutes into flight
everything continuing to go
well first day heading back
and there's the crew on the seco
carrying the right into orbit
to the space station
of course, Miles,
Coming up,
we're waiting for the next traje
call out from the guidance
officer Dragon spacecraft
trajectory nominal.
Love to hear those words.
A nominal trajectory
for a nominal trajectory
and maybe even a little bit of e
in the crew's voice.
Commander Peggy
Whitson calling back down,
hearing that call out from Jan
seven, nominal trajectory
left side of the screen,
you can see the first stage.
It's now beginning to orient its
so that the engines are pointed
towards the land
as we will be descending
towards landing
Zone one in Cape Canaveral.
The four titanium grid fins
have all deployed.
They'll help guide us.
If they don't.
Possibly
they'll guide the first stage
through the once
we get into the atmosphere
following the entry burn,
which will be coming up here
in another couple of minutes.
On the right hand side, the seco
with the Dragon capsule on top
heading up the eastern
seaboard of the U.S.
We've just heard the call out of
That's the New Hampshire
tracking station has picked up t
dragon's physics trajectory nomi
So continuing to make those comm
that we want to hear
every secretary nominee
and the crew echoing them
right back down
good.
Collins, with the crew,
we've been able to bring some
live video shots from inside the
as they're headed the space
and there's another view
of the crew
stage one at Rayburn start up.
And there
we heard that the start up burn
that stage one booster
you can see it there on the left
side of your screen has now begu
Stage one entry berth shutdown
and conclusion of that entry
burn that burn helps to slow the
down as it reenters
the Earth's atmosphere.
The first day,
the first stage sees
high drag
which scrubs
roughly 70% of the velocity
by the time that we
see six trajectory nominal.
Love to hear that call out
everything from trajectory
beautiful view of planet Earth
coming to us from the second sta
Views on the right hand side,
the left
hand side,
our first view of the Space Coas
once again
this booster is attempting
a landing at LC.
One stage, one transonic.
A booster is now traveling
near the speed of sound
by view.
Coming to you
from one of our tracking cameras
we can see the grid fins actuati
to help steer the booster down
statement landing for stage two.
Efforts have saved
standing by
to get one landing leg deploy
there you take one landing to ta
You can see that first stage
has landed back at LC one.
This is the first time
that we have performed a land la
on a true mission
coming up.
Coming up next
will be the second
engine cut off or Syco.
And that's where after after tha
engine cuts off
second stage will host for a few
until Dragon is commanded to sep
stage two in terminal guidance.
For expecting second
to occur in about 20 seconds.
Shannon
copy.
Commander Peggy Whitson continui
to call out the abort modes
pick up
all right on time
shutdown of that second engine
also confirming that
the launch escape system
is now disarmed dragons V six
nominal orbit insertion.
All right and there's that call
we can confirm
good orbital
insertion copy nominal insertion
dragon space.
All right. Welcome back.
You've been watching this.
A very successful liftoff
there at the Kennedy Space Cente
And I want to go to you,
Captain Kelly,
to talk about this, because,
I mean, I, I have to apologize a
I think we kind of undersold
what we're about to watch.
And that's all my fault.
That's nobody else's fault.
But I mean, just what we witness
over the last 10 minutes
or so
was just extraordinary
in that Captain Kelly,
we saw a land landing of that bo
stage, one rocket that was extra
And then what we're seeing,
I guess, happening right now
is marvelous to watch as well.
And that this is
this is really a space travel
in many ways, a space travel mis
that we're watching
on the right side of the screen
right now.
Your thoughts,
if you can help us unpack this,
because I'm sure I've already sc
the terminology in all of this.
But you could tell I'm geeking o
This is fun to watch
yeah.
You know, Jim, when the
space shuttle used to
fly that I had the privilege
of flying twice on,
it was always a lot of drama to
to get it
safely into space
because it was such
a complicated aerospace vehicle.
There's so much that could go wr
But with space X, you know, they
they make it look easy.
I mean,
this was just like a dream,
like kind of a no brainer of lau
And for people in the space
and to see one of my former clas
there and three people
I've never met before, but three
anytime
you're flying new people in spac
it's great.
And to see them get there safely
I'm very happy day.